Hello, I'm Daven Hiskey, you're watching the
TodayIFoundOut YouTube channel.
In the video today, we're looking at what
exactly the uvula does for you.
Hanging from the back edge of your soft palate,
the palatine uvula seems to serve several
functions, none of which are particularly
necessary for most people, which is why it
can generally be removed with few, if any,
noticeable side effects.
In fact, in the West, the "uvula" (name deriving
from the Latin "uvola," meaning "small bunch
of grapes") is often cut out as part of uvulopalatopharyngoplasty
to help patients who suffer from sleep apnea.
Other cultures have long removed the uvula,
sometimes as part of a ritual, to treat all
manner of "throat conditions," as well as
cure everything from vomiting and diarrhea
to rejecting breast feeding, growth retardation
and even anorexia.
Today the surgery is still occasionally practiced
among various ethnic groups in Eritrea, Ethiopia,
Kenya, Niger, Nigeria, Sierra Leone and Zarma.
So if you probably wouldn't notice anything
particularly different when it's removed,
what does the uvula actually do and why do
we still have one?
Beyond that it is necessary for producing
important sounds, sometimes called uvular
consonants, in several languages, including
French and Arabic, perhaps the most noticeable
role of the uvula is helping to keep the throat
moist.
You see, the uvula is packed with serous and
seromucous glands.
When muscle fibers in the uvula contract,
it results in these glands excreting significant
amounts of a thin form of saliva that gets
splattered and dripped around the throat as
we speak and swallow.
In fact, one of the potential side effects
of having your uvula removed is occasional
problems with a dry throat.
With the help of its internal muscular fibers,
the uvula also aids the soft palate in sealing
off the passageway between your throat and
your nose (called the nasopharynx) when you
swallow and speak, helping to make sure bits
of food or liquid don't go up your nose and
that the air and vocal vibrations are directed
out of your mouth and not your nasal cavity.
The partial role the uvula has in this has
led some to speculate that it assists with
keeping the tone of our voices in a pleasing
range, as it could help control both resonance
and subdue the nasal tone of the voice.
However, the soft palate alone is usually
perfectly capable of sealing the nasopharynx,
and thus, in most cases the uvula is not necessary
to put an end to a nasally sounding voice.
In rare cases, some individuals do have a
problem with this, a condition called velopharyngeal
insufficiency, which, beyond potential issues
like nasal regurgitation (bits of food and
the like going up your nose when swallowing),
results in the individual having difficulty
saying consonants like "b".
Given these primary functions of the uvula,
it has been proposed that the reason humans
have a uvula is because it aids somewhat in
speech, making it an accessory speech organ.
This theory is loosely supported by the fact
that, outside of humans, only a few animals,
and this is individual animals, not species,
have been found to even have one.
Another function of the uvula relates to its
role in the gag reflex, as it is one of only
five parts of the body that will potentially
trigger it (the others being the roof of the
mouth, the backs of the tongue and throat,
and the tonsils).
Having something the dangles down over the
throat opening that can trigger this is obviously
beneficial over just the tissue around said
opening performing this function.
However, as with the other stuff the uvula
does for you, it isn't really necessary in
this case either and, for most people, its
removal would not likely inconvenience them
in the slightest, or even necessarily be noticed
at all other than potentially visually.
So thanks for watching this video, if you
liked it, please click that like button below
and consider sharing it with anyone you think
might be interested.
And of course if you’re new to TodayIFoundOut,
don’t forget to click the subscribe button
to get more interesting videos like this.
We release a new video almost every single
day, so you’re sure to find something you
find interesting.
Thanks for watching.
So thanks for watching this video, if you
liked it, please click that like button below
and if you're new to TodayIFoundOut, don't
forget to click the subscribe button for more
interesting videos like this one.